روسيا تبدأ حفلة الانتقام.
وزلنسكي يدعو الغرب مستنجدا
شموعها. والولايات المتحدة تحرج
زالنسكي وترفض طلبه. بينما فرنسا
واستراليا تتورطان مع بوتين.
تعلن موعد معركة تحرير شبه جزيرة
القرنة وبوتين يرحب ويقبل طلب
المستشار الالماني. فما هو هذا
الطلب? وامريكا تجمع التحالفات
تدق طبول الحرب لمواجهة الصين.
فهل تنجح هذه المرة وواشنطن
سلاحنا النووي سيحمي كوريا
الجنوبية واليابان? وزعيم كوريا
الشمالية يرد بايدن يماطل تركيا
واردوغان يهدد بقلب الطاولة.
وفنلندا تمنع افعال السويد على
اراضيها. فهل كل ذلك لاجل التقرب
للاتراك طمعا بعضوية الناتو?
روسيا تقرع طبول الحرب. الحرب
الروسية بدأت للتو وما سبق ليس
الا مقبلات للدب الروسي. هنا
يؤكد الرئيس الاوكرانيسكي ان
روسيا بدأت الانتقام الكبير. وسط
احتدام المعارك شرق البلاد.
موسكو لم تتوقف عند هذا فحسب.
حيث اعلنت وزارة الدفاع في
بلاروسيا عن بدء تدريبات مشتركة
مع القوات الروسية تحضيرا
لتدريبات اخرى ستجري في روسيا في
سبتمبر. فما الذي يحضر له الروس
يا ترى. الحرب تمضي كما خططت لها
موسكو. وبعد تحذيرات الروس ها هو
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن يقول
ان بلاده لن تزود كييف بمقاتلات
اف ستة عشر. في المقابل لم
يستبعد الرئيس الفرنسي ماكرون
تزويد اوكرانيا بطائرات مقاتلة.
جاء ذلك بعد ان تعهدت فرنسا
واستراليا بتزويد كييف بقذائف
مدفعية. فما هو مصدر كل تلك التي
جعلت فرنسا واستراليا تقبلان
الطلب في الوقت الذي رفضت فيه
امريكا نفس الطلب. ربما يثق
الرئيس الفرنسي بمعلومات
المخابرات الاوكراني. والتي قالت
ان الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
لن يستخدم النووي حتى لو تمت
استعادة القرم لتعلن كييف انها
تطمح لاستعادة شبه جزيرة القرم
بحلول الصيف. هناك طالبت
اوكرانيا الدول الغربية طائرة
عسكرية متعددة الاغراض لمواجهة
الروس واستعادة ما خسروه من
اراضي. ليأتي هنا اول المتجاوبين
مع اوكرانيا باعلان كييف انها
ستتلقى مائة وخمس طائرات استطلاع
بدون طيار اضافية من نوع فيكتور
الالمانية وبتمويل من حكومة
برلين بهدف زيادة دعم القوات
الاوكرانية. وبرغم موقف المانيا
الداعم لاوكرانيا في الحرب
وتزويد برلين لكيه بالدبابات.
الكريملين يعلن ان الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين منفتح على اجراء
اتصالات مع اولفشولت. بينما قال
نائب وزير الخارجية الروسي سيرجي
رياكوف انه من غير المجدي التحدث
مع كييف بعد قرار واشنطن تزويد
اوكرانيا بالدبابات. وبالعودة
الى الحرب في اوكرانيا اعلنت
الدفاع الروسية ان قواتها سيطرت
على مناطق استراتيجية قرب
اوجليدار وان خسائر القوات
الاوكرانية بلغت خمسة وعشرين
عسكريا على محوري جنوب خلال
ساعات قليلة. وهو ما اكدته
الاستخبارات البريطانية بان
القوات الروسية احرزت تقدما
طفيفا في دونيسكا فيما تستمر
القوات الموالية لروسيا بالتقدم
ومحاولة اقتحام موقع اللواء
اثنين وسبعين في محيط اوجليدار.
ومن الخسائر الى التراجع
البريطاني. وهنا الخسارة
الحقيقية للانجليز فيوما ما كانت
بريطانيا تحتل معظم دول العالم
وكان الجيش البريطاني يعتبر
واحدا من الجيوش التي لا تقار.
لكن وسائل اعلام نقلت ان جنرالا
امريكيا كبيرا ابلغ وزير الدفاع
البريطاني بن ولاس سرا بان الجيش
البريطاني لم يعد يعتبر قوة
قتالية عالية فاين ذهبت قوة جيش
المملكة التي لا تغيب عنها
الشمس? الصين تلعب بالاعصاب
الامريكية. الطفرة الصينية التي
تحققها في جميع المجالات.
يصاحبها تحركات امريكية مع كل
خطوة هنا الولايات المتحدة تتفق
مع اليابان وهولندا على تقييد
عملية تصدير المواد المستخدمة في
تصنيع الرقائق الالكترونية الى
الصين. هذا الاتفاق ياتي ضمن
مساعي الادارة الامريكية لابطاء
التطور العسكري للصين عبر تقييد
وصولها للتقنيات المتقدمة بحسب
بولستريت جورنال. الرد الصيني
ياتي سريعا. ولكنه يتعلق بالروس
حيث رفضت الصين اتهامات الولايات
المتحدة لشركات صينية مملوكة
للدولة بمساعدة روسيا في حربها
على اوكرانيا مطالبة واشنطن عن
ارسال اسلحة اذا كانت تريد انهاء
الصراع. لتعلن الخارجية الصينية
انها لن تصب الزيت على النار ولن
تستغل الازمة ابدا. مضيفة ان
امريكا هي التي بدأت ازمة
اوكرانيا وهي العامل الاكبر في
تأجيجها. يونج يانج والتحالف مع
بوتين. غاب كيم جونج اون عن
المشهد قليلا ليأخذ خصومه الفرصة
عن انفسهم. لكن ماذا ان عاد
المجنون للرد مرة اخرى؟ نعم يا
سادة هنا وزير الدفاع الامريكي
لويد اوستن يقول ان واشنطن
وسيؤول ستجريان تدريبات نظرية
للردع النووي. حيث تتم مناقشة
سيناريوهات معقدة تركز على
التهديدات النووية في شبه
الجزيرة الكورية ليؤكد اوستن ان
التحالف على اهوبة الاستعداد.
فعن اي استعداد يتحدث الرد جاء
اولا من الخارجية الروسية والتي
اعلنت ان النشر المحتمل للاسلحة
النووية الامريكية في كوريا
الجنوبية سيؤدي لعواقب سلبية.
مؤكدة ان موسكو ستضطر لاخذ هذا
السيناريو في تخطيطها الدفاعي
بعين الاعتبار. وهنا ياتي رد
كوريا الشمالية على الامريكان.
حيث انتقدت بيونج يانج لليوم
الثاني على التوالي قرارا
امريكيا بارسال دبابة الى
اوكرانيا ووصفته بانه جريمة لا
اخلاقية تهدف الى اطالة امد وضع
دولي غير مستقر معتبرة ان مزاعم
واشنطن بان كوريا الشمالية قدمت
اسلحة الى روسيا هي شائعة لا
اساس لها لتبرير مساعدتها
العسكرية لاوكرانيا. الاحداث
والتطورات. الاضرابات تتوسع
ومظاهرات في عدد من الفرنسية ضد
اصلاح نظام التقاعد. وهيئة السكك
الحديدية تدخل خط الاضراب ايضا
وتوقف القطارات والترام في عدد
من المدن من باريس الى نيسة. كما
اعلنت الخطوط الجوية الفرنسية
انه سيتم الغاء بعض رحلاتها.
واشنطن تماطل في تسليم انقرة
مقاتلات اف خمسة وثلاثين.
واردوغان يرد ان لم تلتزم
بوعودكم حول بيع اف خمسة وثلاثين
واف عشر فعليكم دفع الثمن. وزير
الخارجية الامريكي انتون بلينكن
يؤكد التزام بلاده بامن اسرائيل.
كما كان ذلك منذ خمسة وسبعين
عاما. اما الجديد يا هذا غير
انكم تحمون قتلة الاطفال وفقا
للصحف الفنلندية. فان الشرطة لن
تسمح بحرق الكتب المقدسة مثل
القرآن الكريم بالاماكن العامة
ففي اخبار اسندتها الى وكالة
الانباء الفنلندية قال الشرطة
الوطنية الفنلندية انه يعتبر حرق
الكتب المقدسة جريمة يعاقب عليها
القانون. اوكرانيا تتوعد بمعركة
كبرى الهدف منها استعادة جزيرة
القرم وفي الطرف الاخر بوتين
يتوعد بمعركة الانتقام الكبرى في
الربيع. فهل يحل ربيع بوتين
وتختفي شمس اوكرانيا ام انها
مجرد تصريحات تقال اليوم لننساها